Adam warlock fans have been waiting to
see Adam in the MCU since his T's in the
post-credits scene of guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 but sadly that was some
time ago and with guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 being pushed back due to
the whole James Gunn deal many fans were
wondering if we were ever going to get
to see Adam warlock enter the MCU how's
it going everybody it's Warren and when
we found out that James Gunn was fired
from Disney and Marvel it was a true
bummer because we thought that we were
never going to see Adam warlock enter
the MCU at least not as soon as he was
supposed to be he was supposed to be the
villain of guardians of the galaxy vol 3
but then we got a little bit of hope a
rumor started going around that he was
going to appear in Avengers infinity war
or Avengers endgame having some sort of
a relationship with the soulstone like
he does in the comics and it would make
sense that he would show up in either of
the movies because Adam is an insanely
powerful beam and we knew that the
Avengers were going to need help
defeating Thanos but of course Avengers
Infinity Ward came and we did not see
Adam warlock and then Avengers endgame
came and again no sign of Adam obviously
a big letdown but of course rumors
aren't always true and recently the
writers of infinity war and in game came
out and spoke about having Adam warlock
in Avengers endgame I'll break down what
they said in this video but first I
started a new giveaway I hit the 500,000
subscriber market now at the five
hundred and fifty thousand subscriber
mark I'll be giving away an Xbox one or
a ps4 winners choice so be sure to
subscribe to my channel like the video
and leave a comment below with your
favorite superhero or villain so you can
enter also click the link in my
description down below for your chance
to win a Nintendo switch so again the
problems with rumors is that they are
not always true and although it made
sense and everybody really wanted Adam
warlock to appear in the MCU in infinity
war or endgame unfortunately the rumor
was never true according to writers
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely
they never considered putting Adam
warlock in Avengers infinity war or
Avengers endgame McFeely said the logic
right here was to honor the MCU as how
it had already existed and the
characters you'd already fallen in love
with we did not want to give too much
story space to introducing a whole new
person it would rob you from somebody
they
Christopher Markus added we were doing
the Black Panther thing with a brand new
cosmic character in the form of Captain
Marvel her movie had not really even
been conceived yet so to bring her in as
an even more cosmic character made sense
so essentially what the writers are
saying is that they didn't want to
introduce such a big character like Adam
warlock into the MCU in infinity war and
in game because he would have taken away
from all of the other characters and of
course as we know Avengers in game was
really a movie about the original
Avengers Tony Stark Captain America Hulk
Thor Black Widow and Hawkeye and yes
they did introduce Captain Marvel in
Avengers in game but she didn't play a
huge role she wasn't in most of the
movie and it's really a good thing that
Adam was not introduced during infinity
war or Avengers in game Adam warlock is
such a huge cosmic character he needs a
whole entire movie dedicated to him and
the good news is is that we know James
Gunn was planning on introducing Adam
warlock in guardians of the galaxy
volume 3 and when he was rehired by
Disney and Marvel he said that he is
keeping the same script that means that
Adam warlock is definitely going to be
coming to the MCU in guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 unless James Gunn decides
to change anything but as of now he said
that he hasn't and we also know that
James Gunn was hired to direct the next
Suicide Squad movie which comes out in
August of 2021 which means we can expect
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 in phase 5
because James Gunn cannot direct
guardians of the galaxy volume 3 until
he is done with the Suicide Squad so we
can't expect Adam warlock to make an
appearance in the MCU for the very first
time in guardians of the galaxy volume 3
which will be in phase 5 so let me know
what you think about this do you think
that it was a good idea to leave Adam
warlock out of the movie so they can
give him a movie of his own in guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 or would you have
liked to see him make a quick appearance
in Avengers endgame let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below and
don't forget to subscribe to my channel
like the video and leave a comment below
with your favorite superhero or villain
so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 don't
forget to follow me on Twitter and
Instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof